are you doing today sir
mate i am great well am i great i mean
let's be honest
i'm going to be honest and i think i'm a
little bit covered weary today
i'm just a bit over it all because
everything's starting to be locked down
again in london and
it's everything so it's so [ __ ]
confusing the kind of
method they've chosen to use in terms of
tears of danger that i i don't know what
the [ __ ] going on you know what i mean
sure i think i'm just a little bit
covered weary today and
a little bit kind of bit a bit
frightened maybe even you know what i
mean just a bit like
i don't know what to believe well can i
ask you a question
here in los angeles where i live
generally speaking everywhere i go i see
people wearing masks and people here
believe in science
and it is um it's you know i feel safe
when i go to the supermarket
how is it in london in terms of people
wearing masks it feels exactly the same
everyone
there's a lot of mars i mean everyone
has masks i mean there's lots of areas
outside london now where
it's the covid's gone rampant like crazy
again and
but people still meet up and have like a
five thousand person party and then
wonder why
like a thousand of them die or contract
an awful disease
it's very very frustrating let's switch
subjects and get into
more positive stuff because um i think i
think everyone watching this will be
like i've heard enough about covet i got
it
we're all in the same boat um so i got a
bunch of things for you but i'm going to
start with uh
um i have a question from someone named
a
simon pegg all right yeah um
you've probably heard of them he said uh
because i like working in things people
hopefully don't know into interviews he
said um
what do you remember about the wind
chime on his window
in the kentish town flat that you shared
so the win i mean this goes with part of
like
the fact that i've been there's been a
lot of kind of supernatural
occurrences in my life and the wind
chime was something
he had like a he had like a dream
catcher and a wind chime and one night
when we shared a bed we shed a futon
he uh it started to ring it started just
and it probably did that you know there
was no wind
uh it probably did that for about five
minutes and we got so terrified
that we just got under the like under
the covers
and uh if like our feet went out we
started to scream like children
but we were convinced you know because
there i'd lived in this house
that he'd lived in two and i was
convinced that there was a woman a
spirit of a woman in the house
and so we i think we thought that
potentially she had come with us
when we moved uh a lot of people don't
realize
uh i believe you became friends with
simon when you worked at like a
restaurant together or something or
how how did you guys actually first meet
yeah he's
he i worked at a mexican restaurant
called chiquitos
and i was a bartender uh when i was like
20 22 maybe 21
and uh this kind of cute scottish girl
came to work there
and uh we became friend you know we just
kind of got each other straight away
and uh and then one night i said hey do
you have like you have a boyfriend
and she said yeah you know i've got this
guy i was like [ __ ] you buddy
and uh and that that guy
turned out to be simon and uh
you know as soon as i saw him i realized
that uh
he was the real prize not her you know
so you be i got it so you did the
switcheroo and switched from the girl to
the guy
yeah there was like a weird three-way
for like a year and a half where we just
like the three of us kind of loved each
other and like
charlotte and i would rush back from
from work on a thursday night
and simon had kind of set up the front
room already so we could
rush in and like smoke a joint and then
watch northern exposure go out
uh we just loved it man we just lay
about watching northern exposure and
just laughing and
uh being idiots it was it was like a
kind of threesome that you see in like
uh
a french film or uh itu mama tambien do
you know what i mean
without those bare naked legs or sex
right i was just going to make a joke
about the
the sex but i was you know anyway but
the interesting thing is when you were
growing up were you
even thinking about acting or was this
something how did this actually enter
your life
oh yeah i mean honest to god i never
thought about what i'd do
i mean i think there was a brief there
was like a day
in 1986 when i thought i might join the
navy
uh and that but that was it man i had no
plan
i hated school i was really bad at it
um i had like a troubled family
there was like a lot of alcoholism um
and trauma and so i kind of just ran
away when i was
17 18 and i went and lived in in israel
for two years
and that was like my university and i
i came you know i fell in love and came
back and followed a woman back
and started working in this restaurant
and i was
i was kind of happy with that you know i
was i was good i was like a big fish in
a little pond i was the funniest guy
there
and um you know i was making good tips
and there were lots of nice waitresses
and
parties every night and you know
clubbing at weekends
and i was good i never imagined that i'd
have to think about
doing something other than that you know
and it was only when i met simon and
he was a stand-up and he said maybe why
don't you try some stand up
and uh i i did you know he wrote out
this
piece of paper in a4 giving me the names
of comedy clubs and people i should
bring and
so i ended up doing 12 gigs and six were
great
and six were [ __ ] tragic and so
painful so painful and all just awful
um and so that wasn't for me
but he wrote he him and jessica hines um
thing you know after about four or five
years six years of hanging out
he always said i was the funniest guy
that he knew and so when they got
commissioned to write space he said i'm
gonna write this character well it was
my character that i've invented called
mike
and um and he put it in the show and
kind of said
you're you're doing it you've got to do
it
and so that was it you know but i was
i mean i'm tell i mean i hate it when
actors say
i'm just terribly shy before like
juggling on top of a piano in a
nightclub you know what i mean
but it's you know i suffered from
anxiety
and and a fear of being looked at and
you know i've got a thing called hyper
vigilance
disorder so i kind of
i see threat everywhere if you know what
i mean you know
so to suddenly then
be an actor you know and have 100 people
on the crew looking at me and
having to remember dialogue and
it was it was a curse really
and there's there's part of that that
still remains today in terms of
that anxiety and that fear you know it's
i think i've i think it's been like
i've served an apprenticeship as being
an actor and a filmmaker where i've just
learned on the go and i've listened and
i've watched and
i've done i've made good choices i think
and i've just even now every day at work
it's i find something new or i'm
watching people or
you know i don't think i'll ever be
finished what's more challenging for you
uh being on set being looked at by
everyone on the crew or going to like a
comic-con and standing on a stage in
front of like 5 000 people
well there's a part that switches on you
know what i mean and i just start to
it's business it's business you know
what i mean i mean when my dad died i
had to fly to la the next day to shoot
to do to shoot pickups on paul and so
that was that mode
i'm just clicking into this business
mode now and i'm
nick frost you know i've done sean of
the dead and
hot fuzz and here i am at comic con and
i'll be funny and it's nice and i
i love it you know i love q and a's and
i think i'm naturally funny so it's not
a chore for me
but being on set is kind of difficult
too because it's
i've never i mean a couple a couple of
times but
i've never seen crew [ __ ] up really
i mean you know focus pullers have a
difficult time
we're pulling to different points and
i've never seen crew [ __ ] up really so
for me to come on set
under prepared and not know my dialogue
or not know
what's going on that's a fear for me you
know and that's
that fear i think keeps me
getting up at 6 a.m every day to do
three hours
dialogue work and and re reading my
stuff overnight and reading every name
on the call sheet and
you know that's what keeps that that
fear of [ __ ] up in front of
a crew is what drives me i think
i completely get it can you look back on
space
or do you just see oh man like i was so
young i didn't know what i was you know
what i mean yeah
no yeah a lot i've never i mean i've
watched it a few times but
i know it means a lot of it means a lot
to a lot of people
and i really respect that and i love
being mike and but i think a lot of the
time i was just [ __ ] frightened
and nervous and uh
i didn't know what i was doing you know
just trying to trying to get through the
day and
you know i i like i like it when people
laugh it makes me happy you know
so it was good when that happened and
also you get that kind of vibe it's like
oh i could i could do this maybe you
know but
after space after the first season of
space i i [ __ ]
i did my money in like five weeks of
some ridiculous
i think i got paid [ __ ] you know but but
but for a waiter who was getting
essentially kind of three dollars an
hour or [ __ ]
250 an hour to suddenly be given like
eight grand it was like [ __ ]
christmas for me
and i didn't realize what tax was i
didn't know
i thought the show would be out like i
thought oh the show will be out in like
a month
and then people will see me and then
i'll get other jobs and i can
then i'll get paid and i'll never have
to go back to the restaurant you know
so i kind of did like all that money in
like five weeks
uh and then i was like okay so
so now what and i had to go back to
waitering you know
even when space was even when the first
season was on tv
i was waiting while that was on you know
and it would be
weird that i'd get people asking for the
bill and then saying hey
you might from spain you know it was a
i just kind of thought that it would
change immediately
my life would change and i'd be like now
i'm on television you know
listen uh sean of the dead hot fuzz
world's end
uh the stuff that you did with edgar and
simon
i mean people love these movies yeah
when you
when you think back on the making of
them um
can you sort of like can you share like
what you remember about making
those films and you know at the time
that you were making them did you
realize
how special they would be in term in
terms of how much people would love
these
no i don't think i think like that you
know that's not for me to say you know
it's
just make the best thing you can and i i
think i remember
feeling very included you know um
my voice is was always heard you know i
my opinion was always
valued and valid you know and i i
that's something that you know i think
there are actors who work
their whole life and they never they
just act and they never say anything or
say hey can we try this or
can i say this or you know i just i
think i've been very lucky in
in that being my norm you know on set on
a set
and so i've taken that into everything
i've done in terms of having a voice and
and wanted to be heard and saying hey
what about this you know it's
it's sometimes it's not right but it's
nice to
to be able to do that you know i think
i remembered falling in love with the
crew
you know and that life and seeing the
passion of these
[ __ ] craftsmen who you know that film
hot fuzz was my life you know that was
my
that was my life working on that film
that was like a dream and
it was really hard you know edgar was
i think he gets i think he was really
stressed and
tired and it was hard and you know he
put so much into it
that it's difficult sometimes to see
someone you love suffer so much
doing something which should be [ __ ]
great you know
um but it's you know simon and i are
his foils and you know if if
by being a bit sad with us or being a
bit cross with us because we're [ __ ]
about it means
he can give his all you know then i'm
prepared to take that
you know what i mean completely uh i
believe and i'm gonna say this name
wrong
and i apologize but have you been to
gloucester how do you pronounce it
gloucestershire
gloucestershire yeah okay have you been
there since the movie
has come out and do you pay for anything
well where we shot in wells wells is
actually in somerset
so we shot in somerset which is where
edgar is from
but there's a really beautiful hotel
in like a country house really nearby
called babington house
and that's like my favorite place to go
because the food's great and they
you have little cabins in the woods and
you can get a nice massage and stuff
but whenever i go there i always drive
my car through wells it's like a one-way
system
and i always drive it around quite
slowly about three times to see how many
how many waves i can because it's funny
because people were like
that's [ __ ] that's danny butterman in
in
sanford you know that has to be a thing
like obviously you can't do it right now
with covid
but have has it been that you've been uh
how has it been that you've been out at
a bar
or you know restaurant and people you
know
they they feel that they have to pay for
a drink or they want to get you know
what i mean
yeah yeah a lot yeah over the last kind
of
15 years or so there's there's a lot of
people who
want to you know i'll be a pub not i've
been you know drunk for like three years
but i'll be in a
in a pub and someone will bring a drink
overall so i just wanted to say thanks
or i think
people feel like those films were made
specifically for them
sure you know also we got when we did
like the hot fuzz
press tour in the states and and the
shauna dead press tour and then
maybe on world's end too but like people
would bring us a ton of [ __ ] space
cakes and
like cake will weed in and
you know we were kind of puffers but i
think people think they see you as
these characters and then it's like this
guy's gonna get pop hash brownies you
know
hot cookies you know i've heard that
from other people too um
listen i have to ask you uh i obviously
love the work that you guys
did together simon and edgar and you um
and i've brought it up with edgar and
simon many times and i'll bring it up
with you of course
do you think that there's another movie
or another project on the horizon
with you guys working together um oh
god i'd like to think so i mean i think
there's something about the three of us
being friends and making
films what was that film that
he made it over the course of 12 years
uh lincoln
later are you talking about boyhood
boyhood you know
there's a there's something boyhood
about our characters and the fact that
in sean we were you know in world's end
we were 15 years older than we were in
sean
i kind of love the fact that as we get
older we evolve as actors
and the characters we play evolve and
you know edgar's skill level evolves and
and what he does evolves and i think it
would be a real shame
to not see us again in five years and
and to see
who we are then you know who we can play
you obviously got to work with spielberg
on tintin
um i'm a little disappointed that there
was never a sequel to that
uh were you no
that was that uh that again you know in
terms of being
um stressed on a set you know going from
doing shaun and
hanging out in london with my mates and
doing comedy and
doing comedy with edgar and simon and
and then you get kind of cast as the
thompson twins
and we're suddenly now in santa monica
in a kind of dance center
learning to move like thomson thompson
and it was
you know peter jackson would rewrite the
script every night
and so we didn't know what we were
shooting so we'd come in the day and
you'd be given four pages of dialogue
and it's like we're shooting this in 30
minutes it was like
oh my god what am i gonna do you know
feet don't fail me now you know it was
uh
it was a lot of pressure and you
couldn't have
you know that's the thing about me and
my fear is
i'm always all right afterwards and i
always say to my girlfriend
my partner it was all right i did it i
did it i was fine you know
um but at the time it's like i'm never
gonna do this
and my [ __ ]
my pants are gonna blow up and my
[ __ ] [ __ ] is gonna come out and
steven's gonna see it and then kathy
kennedy i'm gonna be sick on kathy
kennedy
and you know i'm gonna knock peter
jackson off his big monitor on the wall
and
and i'm not gonna learn my lines just
just just fear you know just fear and i
was just
you couldn't have picked worse people to
[ __ ] your career in front of
should that have been the case you know
i can't imagine i really like the film i
really love the film i mean me and my
partner
my kid watched it a couple of months ago
i was like oh this is [ __ ] great
it's great yeah no i i completely um
i have not heard much on this project so
i apologize if you didn't do it or
it fell apart but like were you a part
of this the nevers
with joss whedon yeah yeah i just
finished my stuff
like a month ago we started shooting in
october 2019
uh and then i did like a week on it
um and then uh
that was kind of my stuff done and then
in january
we started to get a sniffer lockdown and
then they just shut down so i didn't do
anything for a year
um and so i picked up my scenes like a
month ago and and
finished the season so um
yeah it's it's it it looks [ __ ]
crazy it looks amazing um i think the
script is fantastic
my character's like a serial lunatic
um and it's just
jo justin's amazing because he's
like as a person not as a director he's
really
um he's really giving a generous you
know of spirit and
of time um but when he's on set he's
he's so kind of driven and focused and
mumbly and a lot of the time was like oh
my god i don't know
what you i'm not sure what you want
especially when you've got a face mask
on as well and
uh it's it's it's a kind of amazing way
to work
but i just i love it i love the
character and
i think people are going to just [ __ ]
love it it's complicated and it's
it's fresh so it's a series
yeah yeah it's um uh
i don't know i don't want to i don't
know um how
hbo are going to drop it but it's i
think kovid might have
split a big season of 10 into two of
five but
that's that literally changes all the
time so i don't know
how would you compare this series
to what joss has done before well i mean
apart from the fact there's a
supernatural element it just feels
totally different you know it's it's i
mean even
me with a broad kind of lexicon of
knowledge of
of the supernatural and and the genre
i'm reading the script thinking [ __ ] it
out this is gonna be incredible you know
did he direct all the episodes yeah he
directed all my episodes and i think he
directed them all
got it um i i have a million other
questions but we'll talk about it when
it uh
premieres we'll come back to it so
jumping into why i get to actually talk
to you today
i just want to let you know i had a lot
of other questions about other things
but i've just
cut them all down because of you know
the time limit um
uh so something for the future but um so
truth seekers
is why i get to talk to you i watch the
whole series hey
yeah no um i really really dug it and
it's
fast moving and the best term i can use
for it is fun
it's just a fun it's a fun ride so
talk a little bit about where this idea
came from and
um uh let's just start with the basics
uh well i've said i've always loved the
supernatural and ghosts of being being
afraid
and [ __ ] horror films and you know
and me and james who came up with the
idea for the show
had this idea for this character gus you
know
broadband engineer grumpy
had a pastor you know full of
trauma and grief and you know has his
own youtube channel and and tries to
debunk or prove
you know uh supernatural occurrences
that drop onto his desk but i think in
as a group you know we'd always be
sending each other with
[ __ ] up youtube clips or little memes
of
here's a poltergeist in dublin or
you know people being exercised in in
chile
or like italy or little aliens kind of
scuttling across the road and would send
little things saying hey was that
[ __ ] real you know could that be real
just like with that kind of gang and it
just
became aware we became aware of the fact
that
there was a lot in that as in terms of a
character and
and building a show around that you know
um so i think that's where we started
so the series is eight episodes yeah um
talk a little bit about was it always
designed
as eight episodes were you was it ever
gonna be six or ten
how did you guys come up with that
number i think we i think we just
maybe it would have been six at the
beginning but i think it was that kind
of thing
during meetings with amazon where you
start chancing your arm in terms of
hey we could do eight times one hour or
you know give us the money for 20 times
four minutes you know just weird time
slots and so
let's yeah we just said yeah let's just
go let's get eight you know eight seemed
right for us
there was a chance we could have had ten
at one point two but eight seemed the
perfect kind of
way to build a nice arcade and everyone
to have something to do and
and there'd be enough room there for
characters to be built you know
sure when you go to a meeting like that
with amazon
obviously everyone's looking for
something that can be you know more than
one season
how much are they asking in the room at
that on those meetings
um okay what's your plan for five years
what's your plan for three years
or are you just envisioning this as a
one-season thing there's three seasons
there if we
if if you know if they want more than
one season i think we've definitely
planned for three
um after that i'm not sure you know i
think it becomes a balancing act between
keeping a good monster of the week and
then keeping a good arc and it not be
like
i don't know i used to [ __ ] love that
show fringe oh i love french please
love it fringe got to a point where i
was like i don't care anymore you know
same with x-files it went on i was like
oh i'm not bothered anymore you know
and i i wouldn't want that to be the
case you know
if if if it's three and done that feels
like a nice
a nice chunk of storytelling you know
well i think i mean
uh i think just to not get off on a
tangent but i think one of the problems
with
a fringe or with an x-files is that
um the creators are never sure when it's
going to end
yeah and when they started those shows
existed in a time where
you weren't pitching the network on like
seven years it was like let's just do
one year and see what happens
yeah you know i mean look you have a
three-year
idea for truth seekers so you know what
i mean
yeah i mean i think with true seekers
too it's about keeping it i like the
fact it's set in britain and it's kind
of
naff and and parochial and i'd like to
keep that you know but also
expand it in terms of where we go you
know that's that's the balancing act i
think
one of the things that i really enjoyed
was having malcolm on the show
um and uh the way he's introduced in the
first episode is great
um uh talk a little bit about getting to
work with him because
i mean he's malcolm yeah i mean honestly
i was slightly nervous
um in terms of what he's done and his
output and
you know i didn't want him to come down
on set and
be mad and feel like a loony and
be aggressive and uh
you know you have expectations of
what people are gonna be like i mean i
do but he was
like we spoke to him on the phone and he
was just like
his game you know what i mean he's like
he's vivacious and he came on set and
he knew his [ __ ] and he was funny and he
has a great
line in anecdotes and
you know he's just
when it was just him and me in my house
and we've sat around that table and we
just did our things there
and there was a real stillness to them
which i really loved you know
and it was always me trying to make him
laugh if i could and
but he's just up for it you know he's
just he's not
despite how old malcolm is i'm not sure
how old he's but he's
well into his 50s uh
he you know he was [ __ ] virile and
and
and up for it you know he'd come on set
and say hey how about we try this or
how about this line and you know we'd
give it we'd always try it was always
great you know it's always
just clever and just just a man who
knows his [ __ ] you know knows his
trade and his craft what i liked about
the show
is that every episode it's obviously
like um every episode ties together
you know it's one big story um talk a
little bit about
in the creation obviously you have
certain amount of money to make the show
certain amount of time budget schedule
what was it like when you guys were
writing it
in terms of like knowing how much
money and time you were going to have
how did you sort of find that line
between
what can we write that we can actually
pull off with the resources that we have
yeah you know what i mean yeah
absolutely well
that's a really good question because
it's
we re we overwrote the [ __ ] out of the
show
essentially you know we didn't have
we never had a clear ending
we had lots of great ideas lots of great
episodes
but each episode was coming in at like
44 pages
because we thought they were going to be
hour-long episodes
and so we just wrote really long they
were really complicated
overly ambitious and we didn't have a
clear
idea of what the ending was and so we
got to a point
like [ __ ] six months in where
me and nat and james were just sat at a
table
probably for a week just
thinking well now what we don't know
what the how do we get the end
we do this that doesn't work if we do
this that you know and then
someone had the great idea of let's kill
your baby's thing let's remove
a [ __ ] whole big strand that we never
thought we'd ever remove from the script
let's just get rid of it completely and
our ending is this and now let's work
toward that you know
and that worked that really worked we
really got us going again
um but then the problem we had is
you know once then you say okay we'll
commission eight by 30 minutes and the
budget's this and
you know things that you thought would
have to be in
now can't be in you know it was a real
it was a real learning curve for me you
know to in as a producer to
to have to say okay well we can't do
this
we can't afford to do this and now the
scripts which were 44 pages long
they now have to be 25 pages long so we
need to get rid of half of everything
what was his name in avengers thanos
yeah
it was like editing with thanos
that i mean that was a real skill for
all of us you know
to have to then say okay so let's lose
this and this
but let's keep the characters and we'll
keep foibles and
little fun things and keep it fresh and
moving and
it was it was [ __ ] difficult it was
difficult
um i think we all quit the job
a few times you know we'd all walk out
uh and then like we'd be given the day
off and then even though as a producer
right at one point
[ __ ] quit uh it was
it was tough you know but it's it's did
you rage
quit and just you know
i'm done i'm not coming in
uh but that was cool you know that was
fine
but then you get someone like jim field
smith the director came in and said
okay well this is what we can do this is
our budget for effects and
this is how we're going to do it and and
you know it really
jim's knowledge and his skill really
took a load off us
in terms of coming in and kind of
saving it really you know sure i i
wanted to talk about
his work but i want to now jump
backwards and say
what you ended up cutting um is it stuff
that you could see going in the second
and third season
absolutely yeah it's a really it's a
this will
this will be what we reveal in season
two as as
as running [ __ ] you know have you
obviously amazon is airing it on october
30th
uh i'm sure that the executives there
have watched the series
uh what's been their feedback so far uh
amazon from the get-go from the meetings
we had
initially in the uk
and then here in the you know amazon
worldwide want to put it on worldwide
not just in the uk
and they've they've been nothing but
supportive
um their notes have been [ __ ] great
um and minimal you know
it's just been a really nice experience
through something which was kind of
difficult to write and then
you know it was a hard shoot and
they've been great you know even through
this kobe stuff we were
we were late delivering the show and
they've just been
incredibly patient with us um you have a
lot of technical
jargon that you have to deliver on this
series
uh talk a little bit about trying to
learn all that
dialogue and uh were you a little mad at
yourself for writing it for yourself
oh my god i i said in like three
three separate times as we were writing
the script
hey i'd like gus to say less i said you
know why don't we just keep him as
someone who doesn't say much and
you know he's got a few pearls of wisdom
but let's just keep it down the amount
of stuff gus has to say but it just but
it went by the wayside
and uh you know i always think i'm
really bad at learning lines but
my my brain just switches on and you
suddenly then become capable of just
learning the three-page scene in [ __ ]
30 minutes you know
yeah no i don't know i could never do it
you can
but any brain can no i'll bet you my
brain can't
but let's let's let's uh you know um uh
what is the plan though in terms of for
you because we're almost out of time
um what's your plan for the future in
terms of what's coming up
uh well i uh well the nethers obviously
that comes out next year
um touch touch wood covered wood
and then i leave for los angeles on
saturday next saturday the 24th
um and i am going to be there until
april um
shooting a show which i can't tell you
what it is um
but it's very exciting and um
i'm a bit nervous because it's a big
thing and it's going to be a surprise
so i'm going to be in la for the next
five months well first of all
now i'm very curious what this show is
um is it the kind of thing that i'm
going to be very mad at myself when they
announced that you're a part of it that
i didn't ask you about it
no i think you're going to probably say
why is he doing that
but yeah but just it's just it's a kind
of weird one for me to do
but the character was fantastic i'm very
curious and hopefully there will be some
sort of vaccine
uh while you're in l.a so we can get a
burrito
yeah listen when uh once we finish here
i'll text you what it is so you can
know right hey listen um uh
i have a lot of other things we could
talk about but i wanted to make sure
you're on time for what you need to do
in
two minutes so i i tried to be
respectful of the uh
of the thing but um needless to say uh
congrats on truth seekers
and um and everything else and uh
you know for the next one i will uh save
all the other questions that i did not
ask you
uh amazing let's look up and have coffee
when i get into la we can do a socially
distant thing
yeah fine i'll just wave at you you'll
be in one starbucks and i'll be on
another one and we'll
exactly hey listen nice to see you man
thanks mate cheers steve